after nine games the world champion gary
kasparov found himself one point down to
the indian challenger vichy anand
clearly this was a situation that
kasparov did not enjoy
when he appeared for game 10 he was so
pumped up it was frightening gone was
that warm greeting with anand at the
start of the games here it was chilly he
didn't make any eye contact with anand
at all
kasparov once again opened with pawn to
e4 and anand repeated the open spanish
variation that he played in game six
and kasparov again played this amazing
piece sacrifice knight to g5
his position in game six wasn't that
great out of the opening so he had
clearly had something prepared for this
game
and and captured on c3 all as in game
six
kasparov
captured the bishop on e6
and recaptured
pawn takes c3
and now queen to d3 and it was here that
kasparov played the new move
he played bishop to c2
so he's retaining this dangerous bishop
this bishop is the key to this game very
powerful attacking piece
so he's sacrificing pawn
and then
came this amazing move
knight to b3 sacrificing our whole rook
apparently bishop c2 had been a
suggestion of michael tiles
and anand's team knew of this move
bishop c2 but they'd failed to spot this
idea knight b3 sacrificing the rook
and and capture the knight on b3
caspar of recapture with bishop takes b3
and here
if black wants to he can take the rook
well in fact anand didn't take that rook
immediately let's just take a look at a
few variations to see what happens if he
does play queen takes rook in the corner
kasparov said after the game it was his
intention to play queen to h5 check
now this is a very crafty move indeed
so black can either play g6 or move his
king
well if he plays the king up to e7
then
comes
bishop g5 check
and then the rook on f1 on the next move
will take the queen on a1
so king e7 is out of the question
the same would happen on king d8
and so that leaves king d7
and here there's a beautiful variation
bishop takes pawn check
king takes bishop
queen g4 check
and now black's king can dance all over
the place but it always gets caught
for instance king to f7
queen f3 check
that is a very cunning move because now
if
king g8
then we have queen d5 checkmate
so king e6
queen takes knight check
you see what a problem for black it is
once that pawn has moved to b5
it meant that the knight on c6 is
unprotected and you'll see in many
variations that that knight on c6 is
hanging
so now bishop d6
so at least the rook on a8 is now
covered
by the recon h8 however white is winning
back all this material
and it's a very simple win now
pawn takes bishop well there's just one
move which is difficult for white
it seems as though black might be able
to defend after a move like queen e5
but here there's a very nice winning
move
white plays bishop d2 this is much
better than any discover checks with the
pawn bishop d2 threatening the simple
rook e1
and there's absolutely no defense to
white's attack here
instead of moving the king black can
play pawn to g6 and then the queen drops
back to f3 well i mean you might say
what's the point of
checking why didn't white move the queen
to f3 straight away well here's the very
clever point
black has big problems defending the
knight on c6
fact it's it's pretty impossible
so black has to either give up the
knight or move it away and give up the
rook
well let's have a look at a move like
castle's queen side
but then comes queen takes knight
and black's king has found no security
here on the queen side either for
instance queen takes pawn
and then comes queen takes pawn check
a deadly move
if king b8
then there's bishop to e3
threatening bishop to a7 check
and if c5 then queen b6 check is going
to be decisive
and if bishop c5 then queen b5 check
wins
alternatively if king to d7 then there's
a rather beautiful winning move for
white here
bishop f4
and if the queen takes the bishop
then queen takes pawn on e6 is checkmate
if black plays the knight back to d8
now we see the crafty point of forcing
the pawn to g6 before moving the queen
to f3
if queen takes rook in the corner
then it seems that black can survive
by playing queen takes pawn
followed by bishop d6
and then castling on the king side
although black has returned the rook his
king at least would have found some
security and he would still be a pawn up
however instead of capturing the rook
white plays queen to f6 now we see the
point of forcing the pawn up to g6
this is decisive
if rook g8
then bishop g5
so the rook on f1 now attacking the
queen
and when the queen comes back into the
center
then rook d1
and that's decisive
if the queen moves then the knight on d8
is hanging
so black must give up the queen
which states queen and in this position
white has the queen against the two
rooks well normally this is a reasonable
material balance for the rooks but here
because of the power of the two bishops
and the fact that black's king is stuck
in the middle of the board
and really can't find any security at
all white has a winning position
it's because of the loose nature of
black's position in particular that
knight on c6 which is very often hanging
in many variations
and the king which is really quite
exposed in the middle of the board that
black can't get away with taking the
rook
instead
anand played the knight into d4 hoping
to exchange off this powerful attacking
piece on b3 the bishop
and here
kasparov played queen to g4 and kaspar
was amazing caspar was playing his moves
absolutely instantly
banging out his moves and then
retreating back to his dressing room he
was storming out of the soundproof booth
each time slamming the door i mean he
looked like a raging bull it was
an amazing performance
anand's position is really creaking now
there's a threat to capture the pawn on
e6
so he thought he may as well grab the
rook in the corner now
so then came
bishop takes pawn on e6
and rook d8
and the clock times at this point showed
that kasparov used about four minutes
while anand had taken well over an hour
and performance that kasparov had used
really the time he spent running in and
out of the soundproof booth
and now the world champion played a
shocking move
bishop to h6 tremendous shot
so that now if queen takes rook
king takes queen
pawn takes bishop queen h5 check
king e7 queen f7 is checkmate
anand is forced to move the queen back
but then kasparov crashed through bishop
takes g7
anand finds the only move to keep in the
game queen d3 bringing his queen back to
defend against the check on h5
so kasparov just bagged the rook in the
corner
and the queen dropped back to g6 well
this was the first moment that kasparov
stopped to think in the game he took off
his wristwatch and placed it by
scoresheets a familiar habit of his
indicating that he's about to get down
to business
his home preparation must have ended
round about here with the conclusion
that white has an extra pawn two bishops
he must be winning
kasparov played his bishop to f6
then came bishop b7
then bishop takes bishop on e7
queen takes queen
bishop takes queen
king takes e7
in this position
kasparov has a rook and a bishop against
rook and a knight
and he's a clear pawn up and it's those
pawns on the king side that eventually
marched down the board and with some
nice technique from kasparov he polished
off the game
this was a spectacular performance from
the world champion but as kasparov
admitted after the game it had all been
home preparation he said i spent two
minutes during the game over the first
20 moves but 48 hours beforehand
this game helps me to restore the
confidence but
i still have to solve many problems and
wishes
well prepared and you know it's not easy
to invent all ideas like like that in
every game